cette idée que les gens seraient des
crétins et n'aurait rien compris qu'il
faudrait expliquer que c'est un défaut
de pédagogie qui fait que les gens sont
mécontents c'est prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles
[Musique]
le peuple a très bien compris du mois
des gens qui manifestent ont très bien
compris à quoi ressemble cette réforme
d'abord faite une décision de bruxelles
et il s'agit juste de faire payer les
plus modestes comme d'habitude et
d'épargner les gens les plus riches donc
il ya des gens qui sont un peu une
espèce date d'avant garde éclairée je
dirais des manifestants qui manifestent
pour d'autres qui ne le peuvent pas
parce qu'il se fait mettre à la porte
mais qui pense effectivement que ces
manifestations sont légitimes c'est un
système social issu du golo communisme
après la libération et c'était
effectivement un système un système
équitable qui permettait à certains en
cotisant de payer les retraites d'autres
qui des partis à la retraite etc
donc il faut évidemment repenser un
certain nombre de choses peut pas
imaginer que démographie ont été
modifiées comme elle l'est les choses
devraient fonctionner comme en 1944 45
mais pour autant on voit bien dans
quelle direction ça va et les gens qui
sont dans la rue ce sont des gens
lucides qui ont compris qu'il fallait
défendre
peut-être une réforme mais pas celle là
[Musique]